[Music]
oh wow Wow Snoop thank you very much for
being here you look fantastic thank you
my brother
yeah and I am your brother thank you
this is this is first of all this is you
this is another one of your products I
suppose a snoop dog on the side what is
that it's a Snoop Dogg G penis of vapor
pen
use herbal vaporizer yeah there we go
oh that's nice you could like ice we
were talking earlier about cinnamon
various eucalyptus eucalyptus very nice
so you like to fire this up get a little
eucalyptus going in the house yeah yeah
it gets me open and free minded and you
know ready to do what I do okay and it's
it's any do what kind of oils do you
like what oils do you enjoy to vaporize
I like cush I like Girl Scout cookies oh
and I like bubble gum
you like bubble gum yeah okay are there
actual like so you're getting a massage
what sense what aromas do you really
like when you're giving you a massage
that would have to be the master cush
[Laughter]
can't she say anything else like hi
how about pine scented you like yes that
you like that incense that mr.clean
pine-sol
[Laughter]